翻訳: uchiyama yuka
校正: Tetsuya Kawaguchi
(拍手)
皆さん 海外旅行には
よく行きますか？
旅は好きですか？
飛行機から見下ろす 初めての国
知らない言葉の機内放送
外に出たときの意外な気温
入国審査でパスポートを
差し出す時のちょっとしたドキドキ
自分の荷物をレーンからとって
今 きっと目的地があるはずです
私が今日 皆さんにお話ししたいのは
このドキドキとは全く違う気持ちで
外国に降り立つ人たちのこと
私がこの２年半出会ってきた
「難民」と呼ばれる友人たちの話です
実は 難民というのは
その人が持つ背景のひとつでしかありません
それぞれの夢を持つ彼らは
いつか平和や再建に向かう
次世代の祖国の担い手なんです
情熱系の人も シャイな人も
アカデミアも やきもち屋さんも
そして お父さんキャラの人もいます
それは 私が友人という対等な立場で
彼らと関わって わかったことでした
紛争 人権侵害 迫害
それらの理由から 自分の国を
逃れざるをえない人たちがいます
その中で
日本にやってくる人たちもいます
今からお話しするのは 彼らと一緒に
私たちが始めた活動のこと
その前にひとつ
彼らのストーリーを見てみましょう
想像してみてください
あなたの国は独裁政権で
今日も反対を唱える人たちは
拘束をされ続けています
罪のない市民が沢山殺されました
仲間が拘束されました
脅迫文が送られてきました
身の危険が ついにあなたまで
迫ってきているということです
命をつなぐには この国を出るには
アメリカ カナダ ドイツに
ビザを申請しました
難民になるためのビザ なんて
世界中どこにもないので
一番早く取れそうな短期滞在のビザ
いわゆる観光ビザです
でも実際は ビザが
ほとんどおりなかったり
取得するのに
何ヵ月もかかることがほとんど
唯一ビザが取れたのは
一か八かで申請した
JAPANでした
JAPANか
車とアニメくらいしか知らないし
大体 英語話せるのかな？
小学校の時に習った
広島と長崎の事しか知りません
でも 経済も テクノロジーも
発展している平和な国 日本なら
もしかしたら しばらくの間
命をつなぐとっかかりに
なるかもしれない
唯一のチャンスでした
あなたは国を出ることに決めました
そうして 降り立った成田空港
あまりの寒さに身震いをしました
日本には 国連の難民キャンプも
政府の難民シェルターもありません
物価がわからず
一泊一万円で泊まっていたホテル
手持ちのお金がなくなっていくスピードに驚き
もっと安いゲストハウスに移動をしました
難民支援の団体に教えてもらって
難民認定申請をしました
結果まで３年くらいかかるという
驚くべき事実をそこで知ります
えっ ３年もかかるの？
それまでどうしたらいいんだろう
これが品川にある 入国管理局
申請のための 長い長い列に並びました
住む所もない 友達もいない
ここから６ヵ月は
仕事をする許可さえありません
第２の人生が 始まりました
しばらくして
食べ物を提供してくれる団体や
日本語を教えてくれる
ボランティアの教室の存在を知りました
でも それ以外は
何もやることがありません
寒さをしのぎに 24時間やっている
夜中のマクドナルドに入ったら
Wi-Fiがつながりました
あなたにとって
持ってきたスマートフォンだけが
唯一 家族と連絡をする手段です
目に飛び込んでくるのは
痛々しい写真やニュース
銃を持った軍人 抗議する市民のデモ
折り重なった死体
隣国に逃れる人たちの疲れた顔
この間までは あなたはその中で
平和を願う仲間たちと
一緒に声を上げていました
でも今は 遠く離れた安全な場所から
ただ 画面を見つめています
これでいいのだろうか？
僕は今ここで
何をやっているんだろう？
大事な友人たちが語ってくれる
日本に来たばかりの頃の物語です
難民というのは
その人の背景の
ひとつでしかありません
そして その人がたまたま置かれた
環境のひとつでしかありません
ものすごい奇跡と すごく大きな努力
それが積み重なって
日本に逃れてきた人たちがいます
彼らはこう言います
爆弾は落ちてこないよ
でも 今日も人間として
生きた心地がしないんだ
そしてこうも言います
僕は きっともっと何かできるはずなんだ
わたしもそう思います
だから 私は難民の若者たちの
仕事をつくる仕事をしています
静岡県富士市にある
私の実家はNPOでした
学校に行かない子供たちとか
家庭に居場所がない若者たちの
学校でもない家庭でもない
第三の居場所づくりをしています
普段は出会わない同世代や
弟 妹世代の子たちと
共に過ごしました
３日間家から避難する
そう言ってきた女の子が その後
６ヵ月住んでいたこともありました
しかも 私の部屋にです
朝 自転車で二人乗りをして
高校に行くこともありました
いま 彼女はママになっていて
私の一生の大親友です
そんな子たちと話すのが
私はとっても楽しかった
マイノリティー 大多数ではない側
その中にある ユニークさを知りました
大学時代
バングラデシュの先住民族の地域で
２年間過ごしました
ここは ミャンマーとの国境沿い
見えない紛争地です
そこで現地の若者たちと
奨学金の仕組みをつくったり
NGOで豚を育てて
村の中で お金と知識を回す
プロジェクトに参加したり
国連開発計画の
平和構築プログラムにおいて
村の人たちからの
アンケートをまとめたり
彼らの中から出てくる
提案やアイデアを形にする
そんなことをしていました
気づいたら
現地の 文字のない先住民族語が
ペラペラになっていました
でも ここは
村が焼かれても
女の子が性的暴力に遭っても
戒厳令が出されても
世界からずっと見えない
取り残された地域でした
声なき声が 地球の表側に届く世界
そんな事を
思い描き始めたのは この頃です
日本に帰ってきて
ずっと 自分で解けなかった問い
国家が守らない 守れない国民は
この地球でどうやって
生きることができるんだろう？
これを探すための鍵
人間の安全保障という
考え方に出会って 大学院へ進みます
入学間近の春休み
学生起業家が集う
あるセミナーに参加しました
そこで提案した
日本の地域が
難民を受け入れるアイデア
これへの反応が
すごく冷たかったのを覚えています
「日本にテロが起きたらどうするの？」
「犯罪予備軍じゃないと言える？」
もしかしたら イメージから
こんな気持ちが 皆さんの中にも
少しあるかもしれません
でも 実際は違ったんです
最初に話した通り
彼らはユニークで 明るくて
聡明で 素敵な人たちでした
彼らが持つ夢は 壮大で面白くて
そして ワクワクします
女の子たちが
教育を受けられるような社会にしたい
母国の貧しい学生たちが
安心して学校に行けるような
奨学金をつくってみたい
コーヒーの産業を通して
日本と自分の村を繋いでいきたい
日本で 前に進もうとしている
人たちがいます
でも
彼らの前には
大きな大きな壁がありました
難民として認定されるまで
ひたすらそれを
待ち続けるという日々は
社会的にも 経済的にも 法的にも
とてもとても不安定です
いつ難民認定されるかわからない
いつ就労許可が
剥奪されるかもわからない
不安定なビザでは
ちゃんとした仕事に就くことも難しい
かといって国に帰ることはできない
日本で去年 難民認定された人数は
何人だと思いますか？
残念ながら
20人でした
ちなみに 日本で去年
難民認定申請をした人の数は
19,628人でした
難民認定率は G ７諸国で
ぶっちぎりの最下位です
でも一方で
日本は海外の難民支援や
国際協力には
多額の支援をしています
でも 日本では残念ながら
難民認定はほとんどおりません
命を繋いできた日本で
次の一歩を踏み出すことも
難しい状態にいる人たち
失望 怒り
諦め 悲しみ
そして 絶望
この難しい状況の中
もし あなただったらどうしますか?
もしかしたら
誰かを責めたくなるかもしれません
でも きっと
そうじゃない方法もあるはず
だから
批判ではなく対案を
社会の側から あっと驚くような
良い方法を作り出して
いつか政府に真似してもらえる
ぐらいのものをつくろう
それが 私達が難民の人たちと
始めた活動でした
Not talk about refugee,
but talk WITH refugee.
難民問題について話すんじゃなくて
難民と話そう
これが原点でした
怖いとか 可哀そうというイメージ
新聞や テレビや 本から抱くイメージ
けど 実際に その人たちと
話してみたらどうでしょう
友人として話す彼らは
いろんな世界を見せてくれます
大好きなスポーツの話
故郷の料理の話 広がる夢の話
ある日突然 家の前が爆破された日の話
私たちには知り得ない世界を
教えてくれる存在でもあります
今 こんな空間が広がりつつあります
３つあるんですけど 主な事業というか
大事だと思っていること
talk with と live with と work with
難民について話すんじゃなくて
難民の人たちと話そうという所から始まった
WELgeeサロンで
本当に 今何が起こっているのかということを
彼らから学ぶという場を
毎週 毎月設け続けています
“Talk WITH” 共に話す
WELgeeサロンは
難民の人たちと日本の人たちが
交流し 対話する場所です
２年前 難民問題に興味がある人に
どこに行ったら出会えるのか
そもそも難民の人たちに
どうやって出会えるのか分からなかった時
難民当事者でもある友人と
始めてみたのがこれでした
それから月に１回開催をしていますが
ここは支援の場所ではありません
多様な友人に出会う場です
これまで 中学生からシニア層まで
1,000人以上 26ヵ国以上の人が
参加をしてきました
印象に残ってるエピソードをひとつ
大学で難民問題を勉強する女子大生が
初めてこのサロンに参加した後
私にこう言いました
「清花さん 難民って笑うんですね」
ここにいる皆さんなら
もう わかってくださっている
かもしれません
難民だって 笑うし 泣くし
ジョークも言うし
拗ねるし 怒る時だってあります
人です
当たり前のことです
その女の子は今 スタッフとして
この対話の場を作り出す中心に
いてくれています
“Live WITH” 共に暮らす
ここは 私たちがたくさんの
支援者さんと一緒に購入した
シェアハウスの縁側です
一時避難の場所だけではなく
長期的な「暮らす」と「働く」に
繋がるような
「ただいま」と言えるようなハウスに
ここに 日本のハウスマネジャーと
アフリカから来たハウスマネジャーが
ご近所さんとの
草刈りの時間を共有したり
ゴミ出しの時の挨拶を交わしながら
一緒に少しずつ
交流の輪を広げています
このコンセプトをつくりたい
というところから始まり
一級建築士 不動産屋さん 会社員
難民当事者 ご近所さん
外国人とか日本人とかいう
垣根を越えて
毎週末のDIYを経て
この場所が ついに夏にオープンしました
実は 私もこのようなシェアハウスに
暮らしています が とっても賑やかです
ゴスペルやレゲエの賛美歌が
朝起きると聞こえてくる日もあったりします
さて “Work WITH” 共に働く
彼らの中にある
意欲 経験 能力を発掘し
職業や企業につなげていく
という試みです
去年２人のプログラマーと
今年１人のエンジニアが
自分の大好きを活かして
働き始めました
西アジア出身のそのプログラマーは
社長さんと とても相性がよくって
余暇の時間や仕事の時間に
一緒に過ごしている写真がたまに届きます
彼はすぐにその後
アプリケーションを作ってしまって
裏に ある不思議なコードを
私に見せてくれたんですが
私はプログラミングがさっぱりなので
「わあ すごいね」と言ったものの
実は 何も分かってなかったのは
彼には内緒です
このように「難民として働く」ではなくて
自分として働く場をつくっています
人を 難民として括るのは
日本人としてくくるぐらい
いや もしかしたら
人間としてくくるぐらい
雑なことなのかもしれません
難民の中には
20代もいれば 50代もいれば
女性もいるし 男性もいるし
プログラマーも 牧師さんも 料理人も
人権活動家までいます
だから難民という
言葉自体を覆したい
逆境を乗り越えてきた彼らは
抜群の人間力と 創造力と
優しさを兼ね備えています
難民
実は それは社会課題ではなくて
社会の課題を解決に導く—
チェンジメーカーたちでした
私たちはそもそも支援しますという
スタンスではないので
“I like your idea.”
「君たち めっちゃいいアイデアだね それ」
そう言って
こちらに来てくれる人たちもいます
何かが合致した時
それが一緒に前に進みます
私の仕事は
彼らの夢の後押しをすること
民主主義が
自分の国に戻ってくること
児童労働のない
産業構造に変えること
若者が自分の意見を言えるような
社会になること
国を超えた経済圏をつくり出すことで
これまで届かなかった場所に
サービスが届くようになること
私一人では叶えられない
たくさんの夢を担っているのが
彼らなんです
難民という背景を超えて
一人の人間として思いっきり自分を表現できる
思いっきり自分を生きられる
そんな社会に
受け入れてあげようではなくて
共に生きようという姿勢は
彼らの希望の光を灯し
あなたの可能性をも
広げてくれるかもしれません
こんなカラフルな彼らに
会いに行きませんか
人を信じ 人が持つ可能性を信じられるように
人の可能性を潰すのも人なら
灯すのも 人です
私はその希望を灯し続けたい
（拍手）